now we have two more amazing visual
effects the handsome Apollo Creed from
Rocky 3 and the terrorized star of
Halloween one the crema and screamer
Carl Weathers
and Jamie Lee Curtis
very nice ha the hair is great
no there's on the teeth great thank you
dress is great if there was an award a
knife or looking juicy you'd take it
home thank you
the category is sound effects editing so
Jamie Lee will you please explain to us
what sound effects on OK the pop of a
champagne cork the gurgle as the bottle
course the effervescence of the bursting
bubbles and the clink of glasses clink
and when the lady says why not
fellas that's the effect of the sound
effects so will you please read the
nominees for best achievement and sound
effects editing the nominees are
Michael Amer for dust bolt Charles Ella
Campbell and Ben Burtt for et the
extra-terrestrial
Stephen hunter flick and Richard L
Anderson for poltergeist and the winner
is the winners are Charles ol gamble and
ben burtt
on an April day in 1951 my third day as
a messenger Warner Brothers Studios I
was riding my bicycle like the wind with
a load of call sheets in the basket and
as I rounded the old first national
cutting rooms I took my first meeting
with a major studio executive I ran over
Jack L Warner on my I helped mr. Warner
to his feet dusted his jacket off and
saw a three day career flashed before my
eyes
mr. Warner said when he had collected
himself son if you want to stay in this
business
stay off the bicycle well I took his
advice and Here I am
ladies and gentlemen members of the
Academy the Board of Governors I should
like to share this great honor with my
associates
David Pettijohn Louetta Minh Rick
Franklin Sam Fletcher
Norman Schwartz John rishe John Rowe
Chuck Neely and of course ben burtt and
we should like to salute Steven
Spielberg Kathy Kennedy and our beloved
Carol Madison thank you
the unique contributions of Pat Welsh in
the sounds of et and about 20 other
people and animals which contributed
noises Kathy and Shawn Somers for their
sick breathing and various otters and
horses and things that we recorded to
use in the film I'd like to thank Gary
summers my assistant that Lucasfilm for
his companionship and technical help
thanks a lot